لقد لاحقوا بقوه مستشفى القدس مستشفى
الشفاء مستشفى الاهل العربي والمستشفيات
الاخرى في الشمال لماذا لان المستشفيات
منشئات عسكريه لا بل لان المستشفيات جزء
من المرسات التي تحافظ على المجتمع والناس
في قريه او مدينه او مكان معين للعيش فيه
بالثقافه السياسيه
الفلسطينيه الصحه جزء اساسي من الصمود
ومقاومه
الاحتلال هذا هو الشيء الوحيد الذي يمكننا
فهمه الهدف هو تدمير شرط
الوجود استهداف المستشفيات بهذا الشكل
العام والمنهجي لم يسبق له مثيل في اي
حرب تحصلنا على صور اق ار صناعيه خاصه تلت
مرحله تنفيذ استراتيجيه افراغ المستشفيات
كشفت انشاء الجيش لطريق معبد ممتد في نطاق
التوغل البري مع نطاق تمركز وخنادق في
مسار يفصل بين شمال القطاع وجنوبه كما
وجدنا نقطه تفتيش تم انشاؤها بالقرب من
شارع صلاح الدين ممر النزوح الامن الذي
اعلن عنه الجيش الاسرائيلي ما يتقاطع مع
ما ورد في تسريب ورقه سياسه وزاره
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه في اجتماع الثال
عش من اكتوبر حول اهميه ترك منفذ حركه
نزوح ضمن مسار محدد لفرض التهجير القصري
الى سيناء ضمن مخططات تفريغ القطاع
وتقسيمه التي اظهرتها مسارات الخنادق